in moscow the european european union's
top
diplomat joseph realm has said that the
eu's
ties with russia are under pressure
following the imprisonment of kremlin
critic
alexey navalny burrell made the comments
during a meeting with russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov
it's the first visit by a senior eu
diplomat since
2017. beside navalny the meeting's
agenda also included the iran nuclear
deal the
situation in ukraine and other human
rights issues in
russia yes what the russian foreign
minister had to say after the meeting
we proceed from the assumption that the
eu
at this stage is an unreliable partner
and i hope that the strategic review
that takes place
soon will focus on the key interests of
the eu
and that these talks help make our
contacts more constructive
well from moscow i'm now joined by our
correspondent emily sherwin
uh emily this quite strong strong words
there from the russian foreign minister
is there a place for constructive
dialogue at all
well i think gerhard what we are seeing
here as you said yourself is really a
tense moment between the eu
um and russia ahead of this visit by
burrell
we heard the kremlin spokesperson
calling eu russian relations
frozen and um today we kind of saw the
two sides clash in that press conference
after their meeting and the main bone of
contention at the moment
seems to be alexey navalny his prison
sentence and the protests
that happened surrounding alexey navalny
and really we heard quite strong words
from both sides today
the russian foreign minister was
essentially accusing the eu and other
western countries of meddling
in russia's affairs and of leveling
hypocritical and unfounded accusations
at russia when it comes to kind of
police violence and so on
and uh burrell from his side um
with in not in so many words but
essentially said that there's no rule of
law in russia so those are pretty
harsh accusations but both sides also
made it very clear that they
certainly want to keep dialogue open in
part because
of um all those disagreements um not
only over navalny um
you know relations have been bad since
the annexation of the crimean peninsula
by
russia but the russians foreign minister
also
seemed very much interested in that he
talked about how the talks today had
been
open and they want to keep dialogue open
including about
perhaps the sale of the russian vaccine
sputnik v
to european countries it seemed that the
two
the two politicians did have some
personal chemistry
despite all the difficulties emily one
of the topics of course
uh was the imprisonment of alexei
navalny he's in court again today
what is this new case about
well this new case uh is one of actually
several that are essentially still
pending hanging over the
opposition politician's head this one
today
is about accusations from a world war ii
veteran that he
apparently that i say apparently
insulted him
so accusations of slander alexey navalny
could be fined for that or given
community service now the opposition
politician himself says that this is
essentially
um a political issue that the
state is trying to present him as
somehow unpatriotic
for criticizing even world war ii
veterans world war ii is
certainly considered almost a sacred
issue here and
a very political one of course and um
i would say that the scheduling of this
trial
um that coincides with this visit by a
high
uh eu diplomat is certainly provocative
especially considering the accusations
that we've been hearing from the eu side
towards russia in the last few days and
weeks
dws emily sherman in moscow there for us
thank you emily
meanwhile thousands of people have been
arrested across russia this week in
protests against navalny's imprisonment
around 500 of them are being held
at a detention facility outside moscow
and outside that facility
their friends and relatives are waiting
for news our correspondent yuri reshetto
went there and spoke with them
who is number 15 online this woman asks
she is one of the volunteers outside of
the saharawa detention facility
a two-hour drive from moscow these
people have been standing in the
freezing cold
since the early morning
they want to help their friends and
relatives
people who were arrested during the
protests
some of them are waiting for their
sentence some are already serving it
we have collected warm things this is a
sweater this is a blanket
because we don't know if our friends in
there have anything to cover up with
there is socks underwear t-shirts and
warm gloves
just in case all of this is awful
i even cried a few times my friends are
in there
more than 7 000 people have been
arrested across russia in the past
10 days the police were particularly
brutal during the last
protests in moscow and saint petersburg
on the weekend
and after alexey navalny's sentence
sometimes security forces dragged people
into police buses for no reason
some of them were random passers-by
several cases are now being investigated
the police say
authorities argue that the protests were
not authorized and
therefore posed a security threat in
reality however the police officers
themselves
have at times become a security threat
to some innocent pesos by
these young people say they spent up to
12 hours
at the courthouse after being detained
apparently they had to sleep on the
floor
they were sentenced to several days in
prison
but since prison space seems to be
running out they have had to wait for
hours in a police bus
it's stuffy one young man explains he
says he spent
seven hours in here so far
it's now afternoon in front of the
saharawa detention center
the queue has barely moved the
authorities are taking their time
accepting the packages
and are searching each one carefully
this is all so surreal we don't know
what all this will lead to
but we want to continue fighting for our
rights and our freedom
of course we're also scared but many
people want to keep
fighting for their future on the streets
more than 500 people are said to be in
detention behind
these fans and more young people i
expected to arrive here from moscow
cards
soon especially if the protests continue
you